Today's guest is a stand-up comedian.
His uh his origins are mysterious.
Yes.
But you'll know him from his wildly
popular Kill Tony appearances.
Uh he's on the road now. You can see him
live. Um there's no one like him.
There's no one like him. Uh I had a
great time with today's guest, the
sultan of riff,
Mr. Casey Rocket. [music]
>> [music]
>> Sometimes I can't tell if I'm having
like male hot flashes or whatever.
>> Sure. Men of a certain age, every age.
>> Every age, maybe.
>> [laughter]
>> Men of a certain age being the spectrum
of all ages, yeah.
>> Good. I think these days things have
gotten crazy. You'll see a little kid
having a hot flash or whatever. He'll be
like, you know, you'll see a little kid
just like go like just looking for a
like a
>> a faucet.
>> People are like [laughter] they're
people are trying to do anything they
can
>> to cool these kids off.
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> To help to help themselves.
>> Sure. Yeah, a spicket.
>> You'll see people doing like the the
level we've gotten to in a society of
trying to help ourselves is crazy. It's
like people are playing like a lot of
like certain hurts of sounds that are
supposed to like
you know, help you pass old uh trauma or
help you uh
you know, uh win the lottery. Like
there's a lot like there's a lot of
megahertz that's
variable for different options, you
know.
>> Yeah. Yeah, there's all kinds of sounds
that can help you win the lottery.
Um
>> [laughter]
>> I'm the first to admit that. Yeah, so
certain like tonal
certain certain like tonal shifts. So if
you go like low, like you'll win what is
it? Like 10 to 20 grand.
>> Yes.
>> So but the higher ones they get
dangerous for your like what do they
call it? Like um terminal mental
velocity. Uh
>> Yeah, well when people win too much
money it induces a lot I think it's
called high dollar trauma or something
HDT and you you will see people with
that like rich people or whatever and
they're suddenly eating like rare
cheeses cheeses made from you know
obviously that you know cultivated or
pasteurized in the tears of the poor and
young.
>> Yes. Well, what did they say? It's like
old money at the poverty line. So, it's
like LA with LA by way of New York. So,
the lower the cheese is on like a
vibrational frequency the higher the
dollar amount you don't have to pay it's
like a tax write off. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Oh, definitely if you get the cuz
there's somebody running around with a
425 MHz queso dip right now.
I know there's a truck that just stalled
out on the way to the Hamptons that was
full of it. And uh
>> The engine just could not function like
that.
>> Yeah. I think well when you're when
you're pushing that much
>> [laughter]
>> high dollar dairy and you're pulling it
behind you and you have a [\h__\h]
probably a seventh or eighth grade
reading level driver, you
>> [laughter]
>> The yeah, the polarity there is just not
healthy. And it's like where does the
buck stop? The buck stops The buck stops
when the truck stops as they say.
>> Yeah, dude.
That's how it works. God, if queso made
us freaking smarter God, can you even
imagine?
>> Can you imagine the mental bandwidth I
would have right now? Cuz I had a all
queso breakfast.
>> Did you?
>> Yeah. So, frozen solid liquid. Yeah.
>> Oh, wow.
>> So, you get like um what is it? Like a
fudge pop of like frozen queso fresco.
And then you go like Okay, you go chili
con carne.
>> Mhm.
>> Um pure liquids you leave that on the
dashboard.
>> Mhm.
>> And then you go with the gas which is um
just like a handful of like Ritz.
>> And those are so good. And what I've
also heard is that they have those new
queso whip its or whatever. Like a whip
it like pimento cheese whip its. So you
[\h__\h]
>> Yeah, galaxy guys, yeah.
>> Yeah, you hit a couple of those,
brother.
>> Ooh, I got a stomach ache.
>> Oh, you'll get sick. Yeah, you'll have
to [\h__\h]
>> You'll have to poop. Yeah, it's bad for
your appendix, yeah.
>> Oh, your These days your appendix will
burst or a rich person will hire you to
burst your appendix so they don't have
to.
>> Sure. Yeah, they'll tether you up.
That's what happened to Duff McKagan
from Guns N' Roses.
>> [laughter]
>> He He accidentally tethered to himself.
>> We've been dancing with Mr. Brownstone.
God, dude.
>> Too much of a good thing.
>> Too [laughter] much dashboard queso.
>> Yum.
>> That's our band name.
>> It's too like the string cheese
incident.
>> Oh god, dude. I used to follow
Widespread Panic, did you?
>> Really?
>> Yeah.
>> I think I know Well, not Widespread, but
I know someone in the Tuskegee Truckers
band.
>> Do you?
>> Dwayne
>> Johnson?
>> Allman?
>> Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson?
>> Dwayne Allman?
>> Yeah.
>> I've always wanted a last name that was
a nut.
Bring him up, Dwayne Allman.
>> Peter Pistachio?
>> [laughter]
>> Or a pea. Or like Ronnie Garbanzo or
whatever. Like a bean, maybe.
>> Yeah. Wait, is Dwayne Allman dead? Oh,
no. He died in 1971. Who Who have I been
talking to?
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, dude. It's probably one of those
Nigerian scammers.
>> He's like, "Hey, I want to teach you
steel guitar." And I'm like, "Great.
That
sounds great."
>> Melissa
>> Melissa [laughter]
What's the catch? I'm going to teach you
how to play Southbound.
All right.
>> Kasey Rocket, good to see you, man.
>> Good to see you. Happy to be here.
Thanks for talking, Kasey.
>> Oh, yeah, dude. It's almost Well, I I
misread your name earlier, and [snorts]
that's what even had me thinking about
it. I thought it was Kasey Rocket.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Kasey Object Permanence Rocket.
>> Yeah. should
>> a like a Latino version of you that
comes out.
>> [laughter]
>> Named queso rocket.
>> And I go, "This person's an impostor."
>> And he's like, "No, I'm not."
>> Home?
He's all liquid.
So sick.
>> god, I hope we're okay.
Um
>> Me too. A riff like that will make you
start questioning like your your purpose
in the world.
>> Yeah, things get rough, dude. Well, I
was out it reminded me it took me to a
place when I went to see um
I went and we watched it was at a
music festival one weekend. It was in
New Orleans. It's called a Jazz and
Heritage Festival. It's every year. And
it's
uh they had
Who was playing?
The guy
uh
[\h__\h] Some guy that was going to die
soon.
>> [laughter]
>> And was that
So was that the general consensus or did
you like retroactively you were like he
was about to die?
>> [laughter]
>> He would have like he was out there but
his kid was singing with him kind of.
You know, like when they get the kids
out there.
>> Yeah.
>> And he's sitting over there and somebody
just kind of spraying water on him.
Almost like he's like a like a like one
of those Indian plants or whatever that
help that really
>> David Allan Coe. That happened with
Ozzy, too. They like hooked him up to a
life support machine. I was there. I was
in Birmingham. I saw Ozzy's last
concert.
>> Were you really?
>> Yeah.
>> And did they like was he on an IV and
stuff while he was up there?
>> Um yeah, he was in like a UV light.
>> [laughter]
>> Really?
>> Yeah, they had him in like it was like a
makeshift like Final Destination tanning
machine. So it was like
>> Oh, yeah.
>> pointed outwards so he wouldn't didn't
have to be laying down. But
>> Oh.
>> See, so that is a tanning bed. You can
see.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, you can see.
>> The blue yeah, helped him like he had
like photosynthesis. It made him like
effervesce.
>> I mean, that's the darkest tanning bed
you can get. They're like, "How dark do
you want to go?" It's like, "We offer
like uh
you know,
Pensacola, Alabama, Tri Delta, Pensacola
Beach. Or we also can go all the way we
can do Aussie last show dark.
>> [laughter]
>> We could do South Padre Island or you in
a casket.
>> So that they're actually pointing an EMP
at him. That's a sound weapon. So
he has Havana syndrome.
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. [laughter]
Oh, yeah, dude. And he's just singing
that song. Uh San Juan
>> [laughter]
>> mijo. Have you seen those freaking Tik
Toks, dude? It's like
>> Oh.
>> It's a bunch of people that can't read
and they're going to Puerto Rico or
whatever. And so they made a song about
it. Have you seen that, Trev?
>> I have not. What was the song? San Juan?
>> It's like
It's a lot of people that are having
trouble reading and writing who refuse
to teach their kids how to read and
write cuz they can't, right?
>> Sure. [laughter] So there's like Well,
that's a good reason for not doing it.
Yeah.
>> I agree, but for years people have been
pretending they can and then they show
the kid. And that's like trickle down
ignoramics, right? Sure. It's Reagan
started it. And that's the kind of [\h__\h]
that we don't need in the community. So
a lot of them are going to San Juan and
they're doing this song on the way there
to gain points with their lord.
>> Okay. And then when they land, hopefully
they have enough like spiritual
savings account to not go bankrupt.
>> Yeah.
>> To get a Carlos and Charlie shirt on the
way home. Can you bring it up? You
haven't seen this thing, dude?
>> No.
>> I don't [snorts] even know if he can
play this or not.
>> Hopefully it's not copyrighted.
>> I think it was oh AI made the song. That
was the craziest thing about it.
This is it.
>> Okay. So I am into stuff like this.
Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> It's basically for the learning
disabled, okay? Which is where we are.
There's a whole new genre of music for
the learning disabled.
>> Sure. It helps with like shapes and
colors.
>> Well, we thought for years they were
listening to what we were listening to,
right? And finally people are like, "No,
they need their own music." Play a
little more. Play a little. Just keep
going.
>> [laughter]
>> It's in the boot scootin' boogie.
Yeah, so it's like spiritual dyslexia.
>> Yes. Well, that's exactly what it is.
And I think it's I want to say it's
Baptist based. I'm not sure.
>> [laughter]
>> But it is There's some
>> Well, you can see kind of like
the proving ground of like the
Pentecostal religion as well. You can
see some of that seeping into the ground
water.
>> Oh, it's you know, sometimes you wake up
and your legs are all soggy and you're
like,
>> How do I dry these puppies out?
>> Who did this? Who did this and why? Who
did this and why? Cuz I used to always
know someone would pee in my bed every
night and it wasn't me. Mhm.
>> How could it be?
>> Dude, it couldn't have been that many
times.
>> Mhm. No, once or twice you go, "All
right, I've been making some mistakes."
Four, five, 10 times you get up to
double digits you go like, "I'm being
persecuted."
>> [laughter]
>> I'm being gangstalked by a bunch of
pissers.
>> Yeah, dude. It's obvious that they're
sneaking in through our broken window
downstairs near the kitchen. Yeah.
They're coming up. They're pissing on
your boy.
>> [laughter]
>> I've talked to the landlord. He won't
answer It goes to Malort and on.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, dude. Every time I call the
landlord, it goes to a front desk of
Christian Dior somewhere. So,
>> [laughter]
>> they have no clue what we're talking
about.
>> No, they go how They go first of all,
how can you smell through the phone?
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know. You tell me who's pissing
in my bed and I'll answer your little
inquiry.
>> They're like, "We could replace the
sheets. That'll be $1,100." AND YOU'RE
LIKE, "GOD DAMN!
I'LL JUST SIT HERE IN poverty and piss."
>> I'll sit here in the potty bed I made. A
water bed full of piss.
>> Oh, dude, that
that is what we need is This is what
we're going to get to cuz this society
is getting weird. Can we agree?
>> Sure. I'm the first I'm the second to
admit that you were the first, yeah.
>> Okay.
And I'm glad we're here and I'm glad
we're here. And society is getting
weird. People are not wearing gloves
anymore when they drive.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I saw an animal the other day no
hoofs on his feet.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, what happened to the nuclear
family?
>> It's a big question, dude. I saw two gay
men, they were wearing dog collars, dog,
sitting there smoking in the car by
himself. Okay.
>> Windows up. Ruins the resale value.
>> It's [laughter] just nobody
I don't know if people don't care or if
they've taken our ability to care away.
>> Hm. Yeah, if it is endemic of a greater
social, socio-political problem or if
it's engendered upon the human race in
general.
>> Yeah.
Well, cuz that's a big question because
the first thing you would take away from
somebody is their ability to care.
>> Yes.
Yeah.
>> Cuz it leaves you in a spot, you know?
>> Yeah, well, the one true export of all
of the maleficence of consciousness is
hope without faith.
God, that gives me the that gives me the
shivers.
That's so scary. So, people are now dogs
without nails.
>> God.
And they still think they're scratching
each other's backs.
>> No, they were born on third base and
they thought they hit a triple.
>> Yeah.
It's a different time, man. The zygotes
are different.
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> I'll say that.
>> Sure.
>> You seen a Have you seen a
uh cat scan of a woman's belly recently?
>> [laughter]
>> Like a recent, like an up-to-date cat
scan? I've been looking at like old ones
to see how the technology's progressed.
>> [laughter]
>> One woman had a Frisbee and an eight
ball in there.
That was [laughter] it.
>> Yeah.
>> So, whatever is living in there are
part-time or whatever is keeping its
luggage there. Okay, obviously.
>> [laughter]
>> Likes to party at the park, you know.
>> Party at the That was a great WCW
pay-per-view, the Party at the Park.
>> Was that Was that one?
>> I know they did the Bash at the Beach,
so I can only hope that they did the
Party at the Park.
>> Oh, I hope they did, too. And it was
like kind of a It was a beautiful day.
It was by a river, right? They hung like
a briefcase full of the world's like the
finest charcuterie board in the world,
right? They hung the finest charcuterie
board in the world up, and you had to
climb up a ladder, right?
And then you had to get three strong
kids to And you had to climb up one of
their backs, right? And you didn't know
which one, and the winner got
>> know which one had the best back.
>> Yeah.
Cuz they kept their shirts on.
>> [laughter]
>> So, it's purely intuition.
>> Which And also, if you're standing there
intuitioning which kid has a nice back,
dude, if you do it too strongly, you go
to jail, right? So,
it would take you longer to get to the
charcuterie.
>> Yeah. And if you do it too long, also,
Booker T is going to hit you with a
chair. So, [laughter]
it's Yeah, that was like a good thought
experiment. That was like the Stanford
Prison Experiment in action.
>> Oh, it's where we are.
Um Casey Rocket, dude, good to see you,
man.
>> Good to see you. Happy to be here.
>> It's awesome, dude. You're such a
talent, and it's great to just see you
like in the wild.
>> [laughter]
>> You were in Huntington last night, I
saw?
>> Yeah, I was in Huntsville.
>> Or Huntsville, yeah. They keep changing
the [\h__\h] name.
>> I know.
>> Because they're trying to avoid the IRS
or whatever.
>> Yeah. I actually It's funny. Uh before I
came here, I I took a shower a Gregorian
Gregor Roman shower, and uh
which is of course a cheese a cheese
Danish that I put in a bunch of socks
that I kind of strain it out over my
head. But, I wrote on my hand
>> [laughter]
>> I wrote on my hand last night. I don't
know why, but I wrote Santa Cruz or
Santa Fe, one of the Santas. So, that
doesn't really answer your question, but
I did just look at my
>> [laughter]
>> But, if the question was, "Did you just
look at your hand?" the answer is,
"Yes."
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, I was in Huntsville at Levity
[snorts] Live. That was great.
>> Oh, yeah. The stage the the location
from the stage to the audience, it has a
unique ratio there. Do you feel that
there?
>> I do.
>> Like the height of the stage and the
ratio of the audience is very rare
there.
>> It is. It is quite unusual actually. The
Helium's aren't set up like that. Even
you know, Zanies Nashville, Zanies
Chicago.
Zanies Rosemont's kind of like that.
>> Is it?
>> S- slower to the ground.
>> I haven't spent time out there. I would
love to get out there. Or um I'm not
allowed to go I
I shouldn't be there, I don't think. But
>> Okay.
>> one day I will go when my mom passes.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> I'm going to get out there cuz she would
want me to see it, you
>> [laughter]
>> She'd want you yeah, to see how they
make the spaceships. They do the
spaceships there.
>> She would want me to see it, man.
>> Lockheed Martin?
>> Oh, is that where they're based?
>> Yeah, Lockheed Martin there. That's
where they reverse engineer the
anti-gravity technology. So
>> Uh-uh.
>> Apparently, that's where some of the
scientists are going missing. You know
those scientists.
>> Oh, is that where that's happening
really? In Rosemont?
>> of them went the way of the dodo. Not
not not Rosemont at uh Huntsville.
>> Oh, in That's where those scientists
have gone missing down in Huntsville?
[laughter]
>> So one of them in particular, she did go
the way of the dodo. She did take an
early exit. Um
but yeah, they're being missing all over
that place.
>> It's crazy, dude. From MIT to MIA, bro.
That's the craziest. At least 10
individuals connected to sensitive US
aerospace nuclear and defense research
have died or disappeared recently.
That's two different things though.
Disappearing
>> Yeah.
That gives me more pause that we're a
part of some like greater like neo-noir
detective thing. Yeah. Them just
just dying, I mean people die every day.
>> People die every day.
Yeah, William Neil McCasland, a retired
US Air Force Major General.
He vanished from his New Mexico home in
February 2026, leaving his phone and
identification behind.
Well, Santa Claus or Santa Fe, dude?
That takes you back to that question,
man. That's a tough one.
>> Sure. Yeah, well, somebody let the door
open and the wrong dogs came home.
>> I know who it was. It was some of those
pissed warriors from freaking Christian
Dior probably pulled up and wet that
dude down a little.
>> [laughter]
>> You create enough of a of a
you know, of a of a stream in the
kitchen, a senior is going to [\h__\h]
Yeah.
>> Flash flood.
>> Oh, a senior does not stand a chance
against a flash flood and I'll say that
out loud, brother. I'll run into a damn
vineyard vines and scream that.
>> Sure, and I'll be receptive to it the
whole time.
>> Yeah, yeah. [laughter]
>> I'll be sitting there back there with a
good book just going, "God [gasps] damn.
He's right. He's right."
>> You'll poke your head out of a changing
room, be like,
>> All right.
Never had a chance.
>> [laughter]
>> That old [\h__\h] never had a chance,
bro.
>> Yeah, if you slick somebody up like
>> [laughter]
>> and [snorts] I've said this for for
months.
>> there when you said it.
>> Yeah, if you slick somebody up good
enough, as anything can be a slip and
slide. So, a staircase, most homes have
a staircase. So, if they're slick
enough, bye. Bye-bye.
>> Bye.
Grandpa! And he's gone. You can barely
even [\h__\h] you know. Or you try to use
his real name then, "Henry!" You know,
like that's the craziest thing. Now, a
black grandpa, they'll they'll mill
around a little, but even that the the
stream's even going to get them, you
know? You would think.
>> [laughter]
>> Well, yeah, they you know, they're
probably more worldly and
they'll they'll see the stream
>> [laughter]
>> see the stream maybe before the white
grandpa, but
either way, when the flood comes,
come on, man.
>> You don't stand a chance, baby. That's
the Bible working.
>> Yeah, that's Noah.
The pest flood.
>> That's it, brother.
>> Drip, drip.
>> It's scary to think about.
>> It's scary to think about, dude. Aw.
You're living
uh
Anyway,
you're living in Chicago now, huh?
>> Yeah, I I moved from Austin in December
and I lived in St. Louis for 6 months
and now I've been settling in Chicago,
yeah.
>> How's it been there?
>> It's been good. They have a hot dog
culture that is out of this world. Um
relish, mustard, the works.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> And the people have been treating me
with grace and kindness.
>> Mhm.
>> And I, in turn, have been uh passing on
to them a smile.
>> Very fair.
>> Yeah.
>> Did you miss Austin when you left? What
what what what was the reason of leaving
Austin? Cuz you were things were going
good there, right?
>> Sure, yeah. Yeah, I worked at uh
Mothership for a year and I
I won uh
the equivalent
I won the Austin's not the funniest
person, but the Austin comedy
competition. So, yeah, I was really
ingrained in the scene there.
>> And that was 2021, was it or no?
>> When I won that, I moved there in 2021.
I think I won that in 2023, maybe.
>> Okay.
>> Um but yeah, I have a lot of really
great friends there. I felt like
maybe um it was time for me to do
something else. I'm going to grad
school, so um you wrote me a letter of
recommendation for that.
And I'm going to DePaul to do
screenwriting. So, I just wanted to make
some changes in my life, yeah.
>> That's wild, dude. Congratulations, man.
>> Thanks.
>> On getting in over there. You excited
about it?
>> I am. It starts in September and then
I'm going to write my great American
novel.
>> Dude.
>> Yep.
>> Is there a novel that you kind of were
inspired by? Um like was there a novel
that you kind of read that led you to
even kind of spark that in your head? Or
a book that you read that kind of spark
that in your head? Cuz I think like I
like to write so I think there's things
in in like there was one book I read and
I was like, huh?
>> Yeah, there's some good like memoir type
books that I really liked. One of them
is
a book called Permanent Midnight by a
guy named Jerry Stahl that they made
into a movie with Ben Stiller.
Um, another great one is Sing Backwards
and Weep by Mark Lanegan who used to be
the lead singer of The Screaming Trees.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Um, so yeah, some memoirs and then a lot
of like screenplays like obviously I'm a
big fan as most people are of Paul
Thomas Anderson who did
Magnolia and one battle after another
and
>> PTA
>> PTA, yeah.
So yeah, I love movies and
>> [laughter]
>> I like movies and I'm just as happy with
a good book. I can't stress that enough.
But yeah, I want to learn how to like
write screenplays and stuff like that
and
I want to be a multi-hyphenate. I want
to be a bad boy and I want to be a
sweetie.
>> Mhm.
How do you do that I wonder? I'm trying
to think of like a candy that really
presents itself like that.
>> Patch Kids.
>> You think? Oh, cuz they're kids.
>> [laughter]
>> And there's nothing more rotten than a
kid.
>> Right, but they're but but they're also
very cherubian. Kids are very
cherubescent.
>> Sure.
>> They're very much like the angels.
They're God's little wiggers or
whatever, right? And so when you add
that sourness to them you're saying this
is another thing about them and you
might not like it, white boy.
>> Right.
You might not like it, little piglet.
>> Yeah, so I think [laughter] there's a
lot of that that goes on when you
combine stuff like that. There's also
some candies that some people can't even
get through like we had kids that
couldn't handle Gobstoppers or whatever
and they had to move to another school.
We'd have you know, and people were
like, you know what I'm saying? Like
they just couldn't they couldn't figure
it out.
>> Sure. Well, they it's a lesson in
patience. It's for me when I think of
Gobstoppers, I think that the line of
demarcation is only visible to those
outside the cultural means of
production. And [laughter]
so
So, it really is Leninism at its most
Stalin gradient, but it's it's
beautiful. So, you can see that's
actually a model of the universe.
>> Oh, they call them the Berlin Ball, you
know? That's why, cuz you just you could
There's so much to go through.
>> There's so much
>> Which you have to be willing to do it.
>> You have to be If you want to get to
that center, which is just plutonium. It
is um
a yellowcake uranium. Um
so, it'll make you sick as a dog, but
it'll make you grow in ways you should
not.
>> Oh, dude, [laughter] I saw a kid who had
to take his shoes off in the middle of
one, cuz they just they were his feet
were popping right out of them. This is
Forever Chemicals. These is I And a lot
of rumors is that that Wonka was working
early with Forever Chemicals. That's
rumor.
>> Yeah.
>> But, there's a lot of PFAs in there. I
saw a video the other day that people's
grandparents now have PFAs in them, so
they're suggesting like shutting down
hugs, shutting down
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, well, the original recipe was
Zyklon B, so it does make people like
It'll make you happy in the moment, but
sad for a lifetime, so
>> Yeah, so it's your choice, bucko.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> You know? You're a mean one, Mr. Grinch,
you know? That's what's going on. Short
answer, yes, several popular candies
formerly marketed under the Wonka brand,
like Nerds and Laffy Taffy, have
recently tested positive for very high
levels of arsenic.
>> [laughter]
>> Thank you, Perplexity, which is a
persistent forever contaminant in the
environment and can accumulate in the
body over time.
>> It's not good.
>> It's not good. It's not. Is it worth it,
though?
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> They make the candies good. When you're
a kid
and you get the Nerds, or what was it
for you? Was there a candy that you were
like, yeah?
>> Um maybe like a Charleston Chew.
>> Oh.
>> Inside the freezer in a fridge that's
unplugged. So, it's planting this seed
of like this is getting [laughter]
So, it's like So, like my body's telling
me this is getting colder, but my heart
of hearts is like brother, you know this
is room temp.
>> [laughter]
>> Here was an old trick we would use if we
were driving around and doing coke,
right?
>> Sure.
>> We'd fill the glove box with jolly
ranchers, right? So, when the cop pulled
[clears throat] you over, you open that,
he sees them all fall out.
>> And he goes, uh-oh, sorry fellas.
>> [laughter]
>> Be on your way. Sorry, boys.
>> Yeah, it was just like it changed the
level of anger and and
curiosity of the cops.
>> Sure.
>> It put in a little bit more of a joy.
>> Yeah.
>> It was a little bit more oh wow, there's
piñatas in here.
>> Yeah, these are just a couple of the
candy guys out for a midnight stroll.
Well, the the original tagline for Sour
Patch Kids was there is no greater sin
than the sin of being born. So, that is
powerful.
>> Well, it's something. I remember
uh sugar honkies unite had that's Well,
who had that slogan? Okay?
>> [laughter]
>> Cuz that was a big one.
>> Isn't there a candy called Sugar
Daddies?
>> Oh, there was. And there's then a
website bought it out. But there was
also sugar ain't got nothing on this
clan. Who had that?
Who had [laughter] that, dude?
>> The sugar union? Yeah.
Oh, no, they're like the Pinkertons.
>> Sugar Daddies, that was it, man.
>> Oh, they were a thing. And then you eat
a couple of them and you go, I shouldn't
be eating this.
>> Yeah.
>> You have You have one Sugar Daddy, you
go, I shouldn't be eating this.
>> You're right. And then they gave the
babies away. There was Here's the
craziest part. And this is you going
back to the nuclear family breaking
down. There's never a mother involved,
you know?
>> [laughter]
>> No.
>> Sugar Daddy, Sugar Babies.
>> Sure. It was like yeah, the pursuit of
happiness. It was like gorgeous, but
tragic.
>> Oh, yeah. It was like I Am Legend or
whatever. It was
>> It's like I, Robot. Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> It's very similar to of that, dude. It
was kind of like her with Joaquin
Phoenix. It was just a
just a challenged man dancing around in
a mall.
>> [laughter]
>> Willing to dry hump the air to get a
little sugar in his system.
>> The old reboot. Yeah, they called that
the old Milwaukee handshake. Yum.
>> Oh god, there's nothing that'll make you
leave your family faster
>> [laughter]
>> than a good bit of sugar. Um
>> I thought, and I hate to default to
riff, I thought surely you were talking
about Wonka being a
uh progenitor of Forever Chemicals. I
was like, "Oh, surely this is just a
Christmas riff." And then you
>> [laughter]
>> pulled up the paper trail, which
engendered this idea [laughter] that was
very much factual, where the yeah, it is
bad. It's giving people bone stuff.
>> [laughter]
>> That's not good.
>> Yeah, and the saddest part is the
injuries our grandfathers had real
injuries, like missing a limb from like,
you know, he was you know, got drunk and
he was petting a land mine or something
in Iwo Jima, right? Right?
>> Sure.
>> Missing his wife, maybe put some of his
wife's clothes on a land mine, got a
little crazy, whatever, lost a limb,
lost half of it, you know, lost
something important that had semen
hiding in it. But now it's just some
guy, you know, you see some guy in a
wheelchair and you're like, "What
happened?" He's like, "You know, I you
know, I I I I I had too many Nerd Ropes,
you know?" That was something like just
the the the the turnover,
the embarrassment of our injuries is
going to start to get real and it's
going to start to get real fast.
>> Oh, yeah. It well, it's already they
call it it's at the event horizon. So,
like we can't stop what's coming. We can
only hope to like build a fallout
shelter.
But it yeah, I've met some older guys
who thought that like Nerd Clusters were
like basically like a
like a tasty hydrogen bomb. So, it like
looks [laughter]
It looks like the atom like the the base
molecules of human life, but they eat
them and they like [\h__\h] their pants and
scream at their family or whatever.
>> [laughter]
>> But then the crazy part is they start to
choose that.
>> Yes.
>> They choose that behavior.
>> Yeah. They don't know any better.
>> But it's going to get weird when our
what you know, what happened to you, you
know, and you're like, yeah, I hurt my
back, you know, like I was after years
of plowing or working or whatever doing
trade work or whatever and now it's just
going to be like, you know, after years
of hiding from my wife in the other room
eating whatchamacallits or whatever.
Now, you know, I I have a [\h__\h]
>> [laughter]
>> I have a pH balance of a [\h__\h]
fluorescent light bulb in a mall, you
know.
>> mitosis.
>> [laughter]
>> If you eat What is There's a limit on
the on the package. If you eat more than
five, you get Osmosis Jones.
>> Oh, really?
>> Yeah, so you get like a little guy like
fighting slime crime.
>> Ooh, I love that.
And I'm guessing that's happening in a
Aussie concerts?
>> [laughter]
>> Yes. Yeah, like young blood doing Aussie
covers and then yeah, the whole crowd
it's like Astroworld. They just start
dropping like flies.
>> That's hilarious, dude.
>> But that's the world we live in.
>> [sighs]
>> I guess, if we're really here.
>> Yeah, if we're not just an interference
pattern on a different plane of
consciousness.
>> Let's take a call.
>> Um [laughter]
>> Let's take a call from ourselves, man.
Shopify
You heard me. Shopify
It's hands down the best place to start
and grow a business these days.
If you're trying to start your own
thing, you need to show them. You got to
show them.
Shopify is the platform where you really
own everything. Your story, your
community.
Plus Shopify gets your products in front
of shoppers where they are.
Google, YouTube, TikTok, Shop, the Shop
app, even chat GPT.
We use them for our merch store, they
help. Shopify, they do it. Shopify made
me realize, oh, I can actually do this.
And once I got that feeling, I can focus
my efforts on other things.
Thought about starting a business? This
is your sign. Get started at
shopify.com/theo.
That's shopify.com/theo.
Y'all ever think about how something got
it start?
Like Mountain Dew, for example.
I always thought it just sort of
appeared one day, you know?
Just sitting in a cooler, just a little
newborn can of beverage glory.
But nope, it's actually it's it's right
out of Tennessee. Yes, it is. Real
place, real people.
Two brothers working tirelessly to nail
that citrus kick
that we all love today.
Appalachian roots, baby. It's bold, it's
loud. It's got that I'll figure it out
myself attitude.
That attitude is still in it today.
Still bold, still unmistakable, still
Dew.
It's an American original that's been
tasting great since '48.
Which feels right, man. It just It does
cuz this this ain't just a drink, this a
hometown story in a can. Yes, sir, right
here.
Next time you grab a Dew, just know it's
more than just a drink, it's an American
original. Mountain Dew, tasting great
since '48.
Um
Do you So, you were you you've taken a
break from comedy when you moved out?
>> I did. Yeah, I took like
Well, I did some gigs. Um I did some
shows with Fiona Calli, our friend
Fiona.
>> She's so funny.
>> And um
>> And Matt is her husband.
>> Yes. I don't know if I've met him, but I
guess I'll meet him tonight, probably.
That's at Zanies. And then Dylan
Carlino, do you know Dylan Carlino?
>> Yes, I do know him. He He He's in
Austin.
>> Yeah.
He is so funny. So, yeah, I like kind of
stopped headlining for a bit and then
got back to doing like some local stuff.
I got involved in the St. Louis scene
and I like featured again and
yeah, just kind of started over a little
bit. I'm running a new hour and
it's been good to enjoy doing it, you
know, when it feels like a job, you get
kind of jaded and it's like I just ever
wanted All I ever wanted was to riff.
So, it just things got complicated.
>> Yeah.
>> Um were you happy with like cuz Kill
Tony was was and is kind of like the
Tonight Show in a way, right? People
would call it that. Kind of like the
Tonight Show, but
you know, a different
like amalgamation of it, right? Or like
a present semi-present day.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, there's also dark sorcerers
that are involved with it, but it it's
exactly where we are in the world and
it's great. It's a great show. Did you
feel like being attached to that became
too much or like how did you handle like
the popularity and celebrity because I
would say you were one of the most
popular guys that kind of came through
that system.
Um did it feel like that because
um even in my own life and recently like
I've you know, like in the past year
I've thought a lot about like ego and
what is popularity or mean and the value
of it and stuff like that, you know?
>> Yeah, well, I think I started to assign
some of myself worth some of myself
worth in the opinions of others. Not
that I
I would never look at stuff online,
but I guess I got too wrapped up in
my sense of self, like the poltergeist
of self. Like what what all of this
meant cuz all I ever did was stand up
for years and years and years. All I did
seven days a week. And then if it wasn't
going well, then I didn't know who I
was, you know? So, yeah, more so than
the Kill Tony thing, um that you know,
it gave me a platform and it allowed me
to do all this stuff.
I just tried to take um um
take the good and and not think about
anything else, but
um yeah, I was just really wrapped up in
all this pressure that I was either
misinterpreting or putting on myself and
I didn't
like it. I didn't enjoy doing it
anymore.
>> Yeah, and and as you say like when it
wasn't going well, I didn't like myself
kind of.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, dude. I can relate to some of
that, man.
>> Yeah, I felt like and you know, I try to
improvise so much riff um some have
said, many have said, and
if I wasn't able to catch my thoughts
perfectly and that opens the door for so
much pressure on myself.
>> Oh.
>> Where I was thinking of myself
maybe rightfully so, maybe not, duality,
yes, laws of polarity, that I had so
much potential. And so every night I
would go out and I would try to use 100%
of my potential on stage. And I set
myself up for that, there's no way I can
possibly reach that, which makes it fun
to keep going, makes it always exciting,
but I will never be satisfied with it.
>> Right. And always set you up for a
little bit of failure in a way.
>> Yeah, which a little bit of that is
good. It's good to strive and you know,
comedy is a
it's a lifelong thing
um
if that's what you choose to do with
your life.
But I came to realize
and in probably in December that there
has to be more to life than this. There
has to be more than a performative
affect.
Um I have to be worth more than what I
think I'm worth to my friends
just as a performer and if my whole
world is wrapped up in the business of
show business then I am doomed to go
spiritually bankrupt. There's nothing
that will ever be enough, you know.
So
yeah, I just try it was really nice, you
know, I made a lot of friends that
weren't comedians for the first time in
a long time.
>> Wow.
>> Um and it was just great, you know,
people who didn't know who I was to know
that I have worth to people like not
being funny. Like I can just go to the
movies and I can talk about movies or we
can kick a soccer ball around, which I
never did.
But I could have.
>> Yeah.
>> And if we had found a soccer ball at any
point in the beginning of the year, I
could have kicked it around.
>> [laughter]
>> And it's And it's And that got me going.
So, I would wake up every day and I and
I would make myself a promise and it was
firm. And it was if I run into an
unattended soccer ball today
>> [laughter]
>> or one I could borrow just for the time
being, I will kick it back and forth
with whoever's around.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Um
>> I know exactly who you'll kick it back
and forth with. Some victim of who had
too many of those little crackle bars or
whatever and is now in a wheelchair.
And the last limb he can move is just
soccer him back and forth with a
stranger passing through.
>> And he's to do one of those muscle tests
so he has to hit his knee at the exact
right time
>> And
>> it.
>> And he does it himself now. Yeah,
because it's that's his insurance
provider. They mail you the little
hammer with the little triangle and you
do it yourself at home.
>> Oh, yeah. That's um
Moderna. Yeah, that's That's Moderna or
Pfizer, I think.
>> I mean, I just got a kit the other day
to take a couple cysts off my own body.
They'll mail you the scalpel now and all
of the stuff. They mail you a picture of
a nurse, you put that up in the corner.
[laughter]
And you do it, man. It's pretty cool.
And it
>> And the picture um not to cut you off,
but I think that it's one of those
pictures where you look at it one way
and she's beautiful and then you look at
it the other way and it's a witch.
>> Yeah, dude. [laughter]
Yeah, her name's Ramona Lisa's her name.
It's an Italian nurse and you can pick
what ethnicity you want the nurse to be.
>> Oh, good.
>> And it comes with a chocolate, which is
ironic [laughter]
because
that's what got us into this position.
>> Exactly, dude.
>> And I'm like, okay, I feel like this is
cyclical.
>> Yeah, yeah. [laughter]
>> Great. This is what happens when there's
no free healthcare.
>> Exactly.
>> That's where we are right there. Two
different women.
Um and both of those were drawn by
Christina Mariani as well. Want to let
everybody [laughter] know that.
>> On an Etch A Sketch, which is
unbelievable. I've seen Christina do
freehand, which is if you've never seen
someone freehand draw, I highly
recommend it. But [laughter]
>> Well, she's in that she's in that new
musical. It's a one-person musical.
>> Yeah, it's a one-woman show she's doing
in Edinburgh.
>> I've seen her
>> Yeah, it's it's yeah.
>> Yeah, it's by Statesboro, yeah.
>> It's in the Delta, yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> It's the male version of Statesboro.
>> Sure, yeah. It's Statesboro what by way
of Valdosta.
>> Yeah, yeah, [laughter] yeah.
>> Yeah, I get That's where I went to
college. I went to college at Georgia
Southern.
>> Did you go over there?
>> Yes, by Savannah.
>> Oh, wow. Were you jealous that you
weren't at Savannah because like you
just being like an like I think you're a
creative and artistic guy. I think
you're one of the most unique guys um
in comedy or I think I don't know if
that's the best thing to say to
somebody. I think it's true, but I think
you just have a unique way of being
alive, which I think is pretty cool
because it's hard to figure that out in
the world. Um
but did you ever want to be over there
at at Savannah um a SCAD, I think it
was? Yeah. Oh, you'd always hear about
that place in the South. I went to
college in Charleston for a little bit
and you'd always hear about SCAD, like
the people at SCAD, you know.
>> Yeah, it was like um ground zero for
guys in scarves.
>> Yes, summer scarves too, which is a
rare.
>> Oh my god.
>> You know what they say, summer scarves
spring winter tears.
Um
>> And that's George Orwell as well.
>> Yes, that's 1984. That's
so Orwellian, truly a demiurge of
uh existential pessimism. But that No, I
never I didn't
>> [laughter]
>> And I'm happy that we are bringing up
the tenets of uh the Hermetic Order of
the Golden Dawn, but it has been
[laughter]
It's been a crazy summer. No, I wish I
went to SCAD. I didn't have artistic
inclinations
until I was probably 20. That's when I
um started doing stand-up, but no, I
didn't know. I was more into boozing.
So, it was the only school I applied to.
And they call it State's Vegas.
>> Mhm.
>> And it had some great bars out there.
>> Good bar scene.
>> Lot of field parties, parties in the
woods, mudding.
>> Oh, yeah, a lot of that. So, you got
into that culture.
>> Yeah, my mom's a horse trainer. So, I
grew up in North Georgia.
Um sort of by the the foothills of
Appalachia, I think.
>> Is that like near
uh
LaGrange? No, it starts with an L or a
different letter.
>> [laughter]
>> It's Toccoa. That's what I'm thinking of
with a T. Beautiful area.
>> Uh
it's by like Gainesville, by like
Forsyth County. So, like
up there on 400.
>> I want to get up there one day. What's
one of the major outputs up there or
like exports?
>> I don't even know what they do up there.
The commerce isn't exactly bustling.
>> Oh, it's not a busy area.
>> Well, now it's become it has become like
nicer, like sort of towards like
Alpharetta, where they have that helium
there in Alpharetta.
>> Oh, they got free helium up there?
>> Yeah. [laughter] Yeah, so nitrous will
cost you, but helium's a handshake, and
that's uh
>> [laughter]
[clears throat]
>> and I do sell stickers that say that,
and we're printing them right now. But,
no, it's I don't know. When I lived
there, it was really rural. So, anyways,
we got into mudding at an early age as
as most kids of my generation did.
>> Oh, that's a good way to be it. And did
you feel like cuz you kind of have like
I don't know. You created such like a
unique you, right?
And
do you do you ever think like is this
the real me or is this a me that I
created? Does it ever come to your mind
yet?
>> Oh, sure. Yeah, I mean
>> And it's no judgment against you. I've
just had that happen in my own life
recently. I quit like I took a break
from touring, and so much of my life I
didn't realize had been like attached to
well I always have somewhere to go. Well
I got to get going. There's somewhere to
be, there's somewhere I need to be,
there's somewhere I'm going to be seen
that's coming up. And then now it's not
really like that and it's okay, but it's
just been interesting to be like
Okay, well say that we're going forever
then what you know who would how would I
Yeah. What's going on with me, you know?
>> Yeah, how would I cuz it is it's a
degree of show business past a certain
point is almost not even like seeking
it's like running. It's like you're
running
You think you're running towards
something but you're running like away
again from this idea that I have just
coined the Poltergeist of self about the
the visage of like who is Casey Rock who
is
this interference pattern of like where
I grew up, what my friends were like
what I like to do and then also this
person I try to present on stage which
is
you know, it more or less is me. I'm
just having a I'm just let myself be a
goofy guy.
>> Yeah.
>> But yeah, I mean I have had instances of
like ego death either chemically induced
or just being in a really low period of
depression where
yeah, I I look around and I go what is
all that what is all this for, you know?
Um
but if I did have any answer it would be
that the macro mirrors the micro so that
in the little victories of my life
I figure out my greater purpose like so
it's easier for me now
because I've gotten used to it the first
6 months of this year of not running
around so much.
It's I've been so I've been so much
happier where I I'm just a really
stressed out guy.
You know, I get I wear the world really
heavily. So
if I have to do anything like even just
like go to a local showcase it used to
drive me nuts. It ruined my whole day.
>> Just the stress and knowing that it's
coming. It's hard to operate. Yeah, some
people seem to be able to operate kind
of freely even if there's something
looming, you know? Like me I'm already
like, [\h__\h] man, my marriage, what will
my wedding day be like? That shit's
going to [\h__\h] be
It's going to be hectic. And my If my
wife's here, she's going to be pissed or
whatever, you know what I'm saying? Like
But that [\h__\h] will weigh me down. It's
like on a regular Thursday afternoon,
dude. [laughter] Not to mention whatever
else I have to do. Or sometimes like
Yeah, that's such a cool way to say it
that you Yeah, it's sometimes a I just
feel like I wear the world heavy. And
some people it just seems to be like
this like summer solstice, you know?
>> Yeah.
>> That it's nothing. Like it seems to be
like just like a little baby kite landed
on their shoulder and they just brush it
off, you know?
Yeah.
Yeah. [laughter]
What?
Like sometimes I would do wouldn't want
to go to sleep at night because I'd be
like, [\h__\h] this is just leading to
tomorrow and it already feels like so
much.
>> You know?
>> Yeah.
>> Not to complain. I'm just I'm also okay.
It's just like Yeah, you just think
about this. Sometimes that [\h__\h] gets
heavy, you know?
>> Yeah. Well, I think that um
professionally and
just part of our gumption, and I am not
using the correct word when I say that,
but uh
we just want You know, we have lives
that are based on creation, right? So
they're
we're engendered to create. And And I
know if I have any down period where I'm
not creating or I don't have to, I feel
like I'm not doing enough. So yeah, it
would drive me batty. I'd be running in
circles chasing my own tail.
Um
but it's nice to do just like regulars
stuff. Like I'll read for a bit and then
cuz I'll get so stressed out about like
nothing. Yeah, I'll be like, man, I got
to
I got to like knock up some barista.
Like I got to have a child with like a
barista soon.
And then I'll be like, well, who's the
barista? What am I going to name the
kid?
>> That's beautiful.
And I think it's beautiful, though.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, I feel like anytime I go into a
coffee shop, I hope maybe I fall in love
or something like that. I am the kind of
guy who I do think anytime I walk into a
place could be
gas station, coffee shop, um
you know, tire center, not tire center,
but somewhere a place they're going to
have women.
>> Surely like a Firestone.
>> Yeah.
>> Like a Firestone, but that's been in
business and that has a little bit of
extra loot to keep a decent looking
broad at the front, you know?
>> Like a hostess?
>> Yes.
>> [laughter]
>> there
Yes. Is there anything more divine than
a greeter at a Firestone Tires?
>> And she's standing there and there's
three tires right by her and I'm like,
"Hey, baby, let's hit the road,
[laughter] you know?" Like
>> I got one in the trunk.
>> Yeah.
I got one in the chamber, honey.
>> My car is on cinder blocks right now.
You got three, I got one, let's start a
life.
>> Hey, honey, I put the sin in cinder, you
feel me? Let's get out there. [laughter]
>> I got a pair of cedar tires out back.
Pair of cedar Sinai's.
>> Oh, dude, that has had to been the worst
tires. Back in like the wagon wheel
days, back when um Little House on the
Prairie was just starting out or
whatever.
>> Yeah.
>> Um which has a new season out now. Go
watch it. My friend Crosby Fitzgerald is
in it and
um I've been watching it. Someone caught
me watching it yesterday [laughter] on
my phone at the gym. So,
going to go to a different gym now.
>> Yeah.
>> they'll pull the lunk alarm on your ass.
Like at a Planet Fitness. They'll lunk
alarm you to high hell.
>> Bring up the lunk alarm cuz I got to
make sure they're still using it, you
know?
>> That is one of the better I wish all
places of business had something
comparable to a lunk alarm.
>> They used to just yell fatty or
whatever, you know? Or you know, or
Yeah, they would yell something like
that, you know?
>> Bad bones, bone structure.
>> Yeah, they used to yell steroid boy or
whatever, but now There we go. They
still have it.
>> Dude, he gets it within 20 ft of a
Planet Fitness, they're hitting the lunk
alarm.
>> Planet Fitness just outside Chicago
Friday night. Just got done training
some chest, but you know what?
>> Jay Cutler from the Chicago Bears.
Oh my dear god.
>> Wow. They hit him with it.
And it's just for somebody that's being,
I guess, overtly
what?
>> Strong and in good shape?
>> Yeah.
>> They They hit that like the Doomsday
Clock was at 1 minute to midnight.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, dude. This is some people's Y2K,
dude.
>> Yeah. That causes splinter of effect
that effectively ruined Reaganomics.
>> [laughter]
>> Well, here's the crazy part is, dude.
That guy like Now, we don't even realize
it. They're getting us to think that
being in shape is bad, right? It's all
this slow, let me turn the dial a little
different, right? Let me just mess with
the opportunities here a little.
That's how they're doing it, man.
Um
>> Yeah, it's planting bad seeds.
>> But cedar cyanide, dude, those
If you got cedar cyanide wheels on a
wagon
>> Yeah.
>> That was the worst, dude.
>> It was Yeah, it was terminal. It was
like having a fleas like within your
like roost, yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> That's so brilliant. It's a fox in a
chicken coop situation. So, they just go
wild.
>> But it's built in. Imagine you get fresh
cedar wagon wheels and they have cyanide
in them. And they're like People be
like, "These are cedar cyanide." You're
like, "Yeah, it's the best we have right
now."
>> It's all we have if you want to go take
the route through the Sierra Nevadas.
You're going to have to get this before
the fall comes like the Donner party.
>> Yeah, yeah. [laughter]
>> But you just had to do what you had to
do for your family back then. Families
were tougher.
>> Well, things have just changed, man. I
mean, now you would have a Jeffrey
Dahmer whatever footwear, you know? He
would have a shoe.
>> Yeah, well, Charles Bukowski should be
sold to a rich family as a midwife.
>> [laughter]
>> I've said that for Oh my god, yeah.
>> Look, we are becoming new slaves. That's
what I've been I've been saying that.
Get [clears throat] the F, dude.
>> You're on a chain gang. Yeah, you're
making license plates. That is just what
the prison industrial complex is, so.
>> [laughter]
>> I am happy that there is a problem
endemic to the state of Alabama that I'm
happy we could bring up. There's a
documentary called the Alabama problem,
so.
>> Is there?
>> Yeah, it's on HBO Max.
>> I haven't seen that one, but I have seen
the one about the mall that's kind of
going out of business. Have you seen
that one?
>> About the death of the American mall?
>> Yeah. But this one is a specific mall in
Alabama. Bring that up. This is a great
documentary. If you want to if it's
raining or something and you want to
watch something.
>> I think I saw the trailer for it.
>> Jasper Mall.
It see if it officially closed or not.
>> Man, this was pretty cool, dude. That's
a it's a good documentary. It's
it's enclosed.
>> Or is it closed?
>> Yeah.
>> It's not a lot there. Um, Rural King.
Well, that's good. They replaced it with
a Rural King, which is what they're
going to do for our nuclear families,
too.
>> Well, that's it's just where we're
going. It's like when uh this uh J.C.
Penney closes doors there.
But um
>> Right.
>> But yeah, that documentary's pretty
good, man.
This episode is sponsored by BetterHelp.
We talk about mental health more openly
now.
But asking for help can still feel hard.
And BetterHelp's latest research
confirms that.
BetterHelp's 2026 State of Stigma Report
surveyed 2,000 Americans and revealed
that 85% of Americans believe getting
support is wise, yet 74% say society
discourages people from doing so.
Don't let that be you. Don't get
discouraged. If something feels
uncomfortable, speak up for yourself.
You have a voice. You have a heart.
There's a reason for that.
Cut out the noise and do what's right
for your own well-being.
That's what I've done.
BetterHelp can help.
With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp
is the world's largest online therapy
platform, having served over 6 million
people globally. And they do the initial
matching work for you, so you can focus
on your therapy goals.
Don't let stigma stand in the way of
support. Start therapy with BetterHelp.
Sign up and get 10% off at
betterhelp.com/theo.
That's betterhelp.com/theo.
Have you Have you kept in touch with a a
lot of the people from Austin still or
did you kind of like take like a break
from the communication there? Like um
>> Um no, I still talked to I had to go
back in May and I did my last um show at
Creek and Cave and Creek's always been
really great to me.
I um I'm going back on the 1st of uh
well, I'm going back soon. There's a
special event. I don't want to spoil it,
but I'm going back. Um
So, yeah, I talked to a lot of my really
good friends from Mothership. You know,
we were all door guys together. So, um I
chat with them on the phone and yeah,
part of like um
changing my life and I have no qualms in
saying this, but I'm sober and I and
that's a part of my life and um part of
that for me just means being um there
for my friends. So, like every day I'll
like call a friend and stuff that I
would do I guess when I was younger in
the pre-social media age.
You know, so I'll call people and
feel like all these kids are on their
[\h__\h] phones now.
>> Yeah, I think that's popular.
>> Sure.
>> Um but but not Nobody calls anymore.
>> I I agree. You know what that's a good
thought.
Sometimes I've I've certainly gotten
away from texting and I'd rather just
send a voice note. I think that's better
at least if you can kind of get a feel
what's going on. And even then like I
will enjoy a call and I think honestly
some people appreciate it. It's like
>> Yeah.
>> And I think you just have to establish
if you want like hey, that's where I'm
at in my life. I want to hear my
friend's voice, you know, like I want to
know I want to have some semblance just
in what they're saying or how their
energy is as to how they're really
feeling because that's what that's what
we're based on. You can't pick it up
through text. It's pretty much
impossible. So
>> No.
>> And that that's just a little bit of the
tuning of the dial. It's like where
we're at, where the future's taking us.
It feels kind of scary.
>> Yeah, some of that is lost. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I feel like I operated better too
before as a person before uh technology
got too bonkers. Because I used to like
to daydream even though a lot of it had
dangerous Voldemortian
people in there like even though there
was like a lot of pillaging of our home
in a lot of my daydreams. It was still
like it was a chance for my mind to
rattle on a little.
>> Yeah.
>> So my mind didn't always feel like it
was so attached to me. I did like the
time when you had more space just to
kind of daydream and your mind got to
like
>> [sighs]
>> Yeah, you're right.
>> Exhale.
>> You know, I do that a lot when I'm
driving. So you're saying you would
daydream in a way
that was like the last bastion of free
speech
um for a um mind of uh Cut this part
out.
Cut this [\h__\h] part out.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> My [\h__\h] would be pretty lit. Frederick
Douglass would show up at some of my
daydreams like
>> Sure.
>> There was always someone at the pulpit.
>> Yeah.
>> To let you know the type of energy that
was there. It was life or death. There
were trials that were going on. Like it
was very [laughter]
Salem witchy-an, you know?
>> Oh, sure. It's like The Crucible. Keep
that part.
>> [laughter]
>> It was like The Crucible kind of meets
McDonald's kind of
>> Sure. So if Grimace was like judge,
jury, and executioner, which he often is
in so many of our afterlives as I come
to understand it. Grimace is like a
tulpa and um of He's like an
amalgamation, like a transmogrification
of St. Michael.
>> So Is that what people are saying?
>> Yeah, he's like a figurehead for like
this
>> [laughter]
>> for like this demigod we know as Saint
Michael when he lets you in it is just a
big pool of creamy chili sauce.
>> Oh, good.
I know I've prayed to him before for new
condiments.
It's a
>> That's him answering prayer.
>> Okay, there [laughter] you go, dude. But
dude, this is where we're heading.
People don't want to look at the signs
that like there are children who go to
bed and you will wake up in the morning
and they'll piss the perfect shape of
Grimace in their their sheets. Like moms
are like, "Oh, that's nothing. It's just
100 nights in a row of that." Like
nobody's connecting the dots of where
we're going.
>> No, like that you piss the Shroud of
Turin. Like
>> [laughter]
>> You pissed a perfect exact Gollum
of [clears throat] things come to pass.
>> Dude, yeah. I know they cracked some kid
open and he had 11 scenes from The
Patriot with Mel Gibson inside of him.
It's like
>> And Heath Ledger.
>> Yeah, I know. [laughter]
>> It Yeah, it was my understanding it was
just the Gibson scenes. So, there was no
Heath Ledger which is like, "Okay, what
is this? The director's cut?" So
>> is this? And then he just screamed aim
small, miss small and disappeared into
the ether. It's just where we are.
Um
you mentioned What do you want to say?
>> No, I'm just kind of just like coming to
terms with some of that.
Cuz it is it's an absolute, you know,
and my will like my will's greater than
myself, you know, I have a higher
purpose and some of that is Grimace like
putting a kid in a wood chipper.
>> Yeah. I remember when we were in school
and some kids didn't understand how the
greater than or less than signs worked
and we weren't allowed to those kids and
[laughter] that always kind of made me
upset.
>> I don't know. I'm not even trying to get
into some of that stuff, but
>> Yeah, facts.
>> I don't know my times tables.
>> Oh, yeah. Well
>> What do we do? Where do we go from here?
>> You're right, dude. And it's weird if
I'm willing to give you a pass, but I'm
not willing to give them, you know?
>> Sure.
>> Well, it's not a meritocracy, you know?
>> It was.
>> It was in a perfect world [laughter]
when Tolstoy was kicking around with
Dostoevsky.
It was doing Downton
>> Abbey was doing their [\h__\h] when that
[\h__\h] was popping.
>> Oh, yeah. When they Oh my god, me and my
boys, we would sit down every Downton
Abbey Tuesday.
>> It was good, dude.
>> It was so good.
>> [\h__\h] season of it?
>> So good.
>> God, I wanted to be a butler. I'd be a
butler's son or whatever.
>> Yeah, just to be grandfathered into the
butler trade would be such a blessing.
>> And the butler comes walking in, he's
like, "Gregory's gay." You know, and
you're like, "What?"
>> He [snorts] told you in confidence?
>> Dude, dude, just get the dishes.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> Leave your son out of this. That guy was
so good, bro.
>> Yeah. It's weird to see him like that,
not sleeping standing up in a closet.
Cuz
>> [laughter]
>> Well, he was a stunt double in a lot of
coffins.
>> Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> And people don't give him any credit,
you know?
>> No.
>> What was his name? That guy was a great
actor.
>> He looks like the guy who did the
Wilhelm scream. You know what I'm
talking about? The Wilhelm scream.
>> won the contest?
>> There's something called the Wilhelm
scream, which is this scream they use in
like a million different movies.
>> Mhm.
>> You would recognize it if you play it.
>> Jim Carter.
>> I think he's the guy who does that
special special scream from the golden
age of Hollywood.
>> Well, let's let's look that up, the
Wilhelm scream.
Um say it again?
>> [screaming]
[laughter]
>> You sure?
That sounds like Wilhelm Memphis.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> Where is that from?
>> Yeah, that's Beale Street. If Beale
Street could talk,
>> [laughter]
>> it would sound like that.
Wow.
So, yeah, that guy did that, and then I
guess he had to go to court to get like
uh his residuals from it.
>> You really?
>> So, that scream there they're calling it
the the scream of hope. So, it was one
of the first famous
>> of hope?
Are you serious?
>> So, yeah, it's like a symbol. It's
[laughter] like
>> How bad has it gotten?
>> Well, it's like, you know, like South
Africa used Rodriguez and his albums to
like fight against apartheid. So, like
this is the American version of that.
>> Yeah, I remember in Tyler Perry's
Mandela goes to jail, I think.
>> [laughter]
>> Exactly. Exactly. So, Sheb Wooley was
the stage name of that old old guy who
lived in the closet. And he just did
this he did this [laughter] special
scream that became like a message of
hope.
>> Oh, I love hearing this. And this is
says it right here and this says the
famous Wilhelm scream was originally
voiced by actor musician Sheb Wooley in
1951. It was recorded for the movie
Distant Drums for a scene where a man is
bitten and dragged underwater by an
alligator. Play one more time and let's
put it let's put it where it belongs in
our heads.
>> [screaming]
[laughter]
>> Oh, he gay, bro. That's all I'm saying,
bro.
>> He's a friend of Dorothy.
>> Yeah, yeah, let's just say he's a friend
of Dorothy.
>> That's what they used to say.
>> Or yeah, he's a Toto owner.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah, people would say that.
Have [laughter] you seen that guy in
Austin?
>> He got a Toto?
>> Who goes on the streets and he's like,
you think this guy's gay, man? Have you
seen those videos?
>> No.
>> Oh my god.
>> Uh-uh.
>> Pull this up. This is worth watching,
dude. This is one of the best things
that's ever happened, I think.
And it just goes to show how men are
obsessed
with
um
with pointing the 11th finger at each
other.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, they're making a call to the
bullpen, but nobody's showing up.
>> Yeah.
>> Sure.
>> You know what I'm talking about, Trev?
>> Yeah, we
>> Have you ever seen Elijah Wood? Um he
rides around Austin on a little scooter
sometimes.
>> No, but I would believe that.
>> I know, right?
>> And I hope that happens.
>> Me too. I hope that for the rest of the
world and the rest of today.
>> Well, here's what we should do. We
should see if
>> one day in Austin that changed
everything.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay. So, this is how rumors get started
here.
And let's go into this. Let's click on
this. This is a picture for those at
home of Elijah Wood on a Bird scooter.
>> Oh my god, he's ripping a heater.
>> [\h__\h] yeah, he is, dude.
>> pro-union, ripping a heater.
>> Bro, he saved the whole freaking world.
>> The guy that changed everything. He's
got a thousand-yard stare that's staring
into the future of American society.
>> He's hunting Gollums, dude.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, he's hunting the Nephilim. He's
the watcher.
>> Yeah, dude. Oh, definitely. He's got his
ball certificates out.
Um
Can you What did that say? Did it say
anything else about him on that? That's
crazy. And did you see him when you were
there?
>> I have never seen something like this in
person.
It's by Evil Mopac. So, this is Yeah,
this is spell work right here. This is
deep. [laughter]
Why'd you I spell work I told you equals
magic. I [\h__\h] told you.
>> Oh.
>> This is an incantation.
>> Despite my joke ways online, I actually
quite miserly with my laughs. It's just
how I was paved. But when something gets
me, it really gets me. So, on the
fateful day when I saw the most
quintessential 2018 Austin photo humanly
possible pop into my Twitter timeline, I
was reduced to a queave.
>> Okay, Lovecraft. What are all these
adjectives? [laughter]
>> This is just some [\h__\h] Overwatch
addict putting this [\h__\h] together. Can
you zoom down a little?
>> [laughter]
>> Does this say anything else after that
part? Oh, that's it. Oh, they have to
pay to read it. Come on.
>> it was taken in September 2018 in
Austin, Texas while attending the
Fantastic Festival. He tried out the
app-based rental scooter Lime for the
first time while holding a cigarette.
>> Oh, that's pretty cool.
>> That is so cool. This is like pictures
taken moments before tragedy.
>> Let's hope not. I mean, well actually it
would be he's fine, so it's not.
>> He He avoided his destiny.
>> Yeah, we're not casting anything. That's
the only thing I don't want to cast
anything.
>> No.
>> [snorts]
>> No, no, no, no, no.
>> to do any spell work.
>> No, and we and we don't have to and I I
don't do talismanic magic. It's my
understanding neither does Elijah Wood,
so
>> But I saw you brought something. I saw
you a little thing a bag of hair or
whatever. What's that for?
>> Yeah, sure. So that's spare hair. So um
that's hair care. Um it's part of my
self-care routine. So if anyone
while I'm talking to them says like hey,
a big clump of your hair just fell out.
>> You're ready to go?
>> Yeah, I'll be like, oh thank you. First
of all, thanks for holding space for
that. Um
>> [laughter]
>> second of all, do you have any Elmer's
glue? So yeah, it allows me to kind of
like keep my hairline like how I want
it, so
>> Yeah, it looks great.
>> Thanks, yeah.
>> And I think if someone mails you their
hair and you care for it.
>> It's everything.
>> I mean, that's
>> [laughter]
>> crazy, dude.
>> That's what fatherhood means to me.
It's like having a son who's bald as a
baby like Caillou or like Franklin the
Turtle
>> [laughter]
>> and then just getting a big old glob of
mush and just
smooching it on top of that freaking
think tank.
>> What? One time we were on a cruise ship.
Not one of the ones that like you've
sinking or has like [\h__\h] floating on it
or whatever this Netflix keeps
advertising, but one of the regular
ones. We were on there and we had
Halloween, but we didn't have any
costume store. So some guy would sold a
bunch of his pubic hair and people were
like gluing it on with honey as mustache
and stuff. So everybody could be like
the husband from um
>> [laughter]
>> Everybody could be Sam Elliott.
>> Oh, that's so cool.
>> Let's play this video right here.
>> [laughter]
>> Other than that, how was the play, Mrs.
Lincoln?
>> You think people going to think that?
>> I think most people will, but I don't
know.
>> Like he gay straight.
He got a little like he gay in the
[\h__\h]
He got booty parted [\h__\h]
Why you say that?
>> That [\h__\h] got this little like gay ass
outfit on like it's Halloween and [\h__\h]
Like, what the [\h__\h] you try to do,
[\h__\h]
>> All right, you gay or straight?
>> I'm straight as a [\h__\h]
>> You think other people going to think
that?
>> Like, they going to know that.
>> Feel like he gay or straight.
>> [\h__\h] gay as a [\h__\h]
>> Why you say that?
>> Look at that dumb ass hair.
[\h__\h] all right.
>> You gay or straight?
>> Straight, bro. What's up?
>> You think other people going to think
that?
>> Feel like he gay or straight.
>> That's a small man.
>> Why you say that?
>> Because, look at him.
>> You gay or straight? ALL RIGHT, [\h__\h]
>> ALL RIGHT, LOOK AT HIM.
>> I'M STRAIGHT.
>> YOU THINK other people going to think
that?
>> Hey, baby.
>> [laughter]
>> They better.
>> Feel like he gay or straight.
>> That [\h__\h] is gay as [\h__\h]
>> Every time, dude.
>> Why you say that?
>> Look how this [\h__\h] is in here.
What the [\h__\h] That [\h__\h] popped up like
a little bad [\h__\h]
>> You gay or straight?
>> I'm straight as a a pencil.
>> Bro, you think other people going to
think that?
>> Hell yeah.
>> You feel like he gay or straight?
>> He could be bisexual.
>> Facts.
>> Why you say that?
>> Everybody bisexual.
>> Nah. YOU GAY OR STRAIGHT?
>> I DON'T CARE WHAT the [\h__\h] they think.
They should kiss my ass.
>> Feel like he gay or straight.
>> Gay as [\h__\h]
>> Why you say that?
>> What the [\h__\h] is he wearing, [\h__\h]
>> Who is that John Jones? Who is this?
>> That's Bon's Jones.
>> You think other people
>> Is that Indiana John Jones, dude? Who
the
>> [laughter]
>> [\h__\h] is that?
George Jones, Joe.
>> That's good. Yeah. That's uh pretty
cool. That was a cool outfit. I'd like
to get to a place
in comfortability and
metaphysical wellness where I could wear
a chain around my neck with a lock on
it.
>> Yeah, I think you could [laughter] do
it, dude.
>> I think I could pull it off. I used to
paint my nails and then I would go to
rehab like a week later.
>> Oh, yeah. It happened
>> [laughter]
>> It happened several times in my adult
life. I would paint my nails like, you
know, twirling my hair, talking on a
corded phone, like paint my nails. And
then I'd wake up like a couple days
later and I was like, I need help.
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> I was like, I'm being fashion forward,
but I am turning the clock back.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, you're a [\h__\h] just a little leap
year, you were.
>> Yeah, I'm a leap year baby. I have
Benjamin Button's disease, but I'm right
in the middle between young and old, so
I'm normal.
>> Mhm.
>> Brutal.
>> Oh.
Um so so Brody, so you did you
uh
can I ask you something about it?
>> Mhm.
>> How has it been? Um was there a like a a
point that you got was it like drinking
was it or was it just like you were just
feeling like disconnected from your own
life and and congrats on uh having the
wherewithal to like try something new.
Like even just to
be like, "Okay, I've been in Austin.
This is what's going on. I'm going to
try something new." It's some It's so
hard to come to that conclusion for some
of us.
>> Yeah. Well,
um
I struggled with those things since I
was a kid and I would have long
stretches of sobriety. Um
when I was younger, it would be alcohol
and then um where I grew up in Georgia,
um
it would has I was in high school during
like the Purdue Pharmaceuticals like
that all that stuff.
>> Oh, really?
>> Um so a lot of my friends um got
addicted to like OxyContin and stuff
like that. Um so yeah, so like that I
was exposed to um drug use like that
when I was younger, so um off and on and
mostly I
would sometimes go back to it when I
couldn't deal with pressure. You know,
there's a lot of excuses for things like
that. Um
but yeah, it gotten to a point where I
no longer wanted to do comedy. I no
longer wanted to really do anything. I
just felt like almost not like I had
wasted my life cuz I love what I do and
I I really like getting to meet people
and I love make people happy. But it got
to be too much when coupled with um
a habit that I had developed of various
um drugs and alcohol and things like
that.
>> Yeah.
>> Um where I was like something has to
change. Like something has to change. I
I had Right, so you got to that point
something has to change.
>> Yeah. I had resigned myself to the idea
of a certain death, and that did not
scare me. It would have been um I looked
at it at that point as some sort of like
welcomed relief. Like I had gone past
the point of
anyone being able to help me or me being
able to help myself. And then, when I
did reach out and I did seek some help
for that stuff,
um I realized that that's not what I
wanted at all. What I really wanted was
to figure out a better way to live.
>> Mhm.
>> That I really just wanted to have some
peace in my life that I knew, even in
the throws of it,
was not being given to me by drugs and
alcohol. It was the opposite of that. It
was making my life a thousand times
worse.
>> Ooh.
>> And by um yeah, I've been able to cut so
much guff out of my life, so much guff
and slime. And
I'm able to look around today and I know
that uh I don't have any I don't live in
shame about my life. I don't do th- I
don't say things to thing
I don't say things to people I don't
mean.
>> Mhm.
>> I don't hurt my friends' feelings. I can
be a better partner. I can kick a soccer
ball. I can uh
>> [laughter]
>> It's basically it was soccer ball-based.
So, I looked around and I was like, "You
know what? This house is missing
a
a soccer ball." And then I caught a
glimpse of myself in the mirror and I
said, "You're in no condition to kick a
soccer ball.
>> [laughter]
>> You're going to hurt somebody." Um
But it's just really basic things, you
know, I wanted to be involved again. I
wanted to be in the stream of of life.
And
>> Yeah, dude.
>> It's been so beautiful. I'm just so
happy, and I don't think it's a
temporary happiness. I think it'll be
sustained if I continue to work on
myself.
>> I know, huh?
>> Yeah.
>> Are you able to look and see uh congrats
to you, man. I know it's not like a
thing that it's like is it a congrats
thing, but it's a it when you think
about our world to take a break from
anything
>> Yeah.
>> and make a commitment to take a break
from something
>> Mhm. and do it, it's tough.
>> Oh my gosh, yeah.
>> for any of us. We're all We're There's
so many ways to get addicted to distract
ourselves from us.
>> Absolutely. It's a It's a diseased
thinking of I'm I'm constantly cuz you
know, I can do with all kinds of things.
I I would spend too much money. I would
I would gamble. I would do these things
that on paper seem like a lesser
thing than
the usage of substances. And they are,
but it's all just a symptom of a greater
I want to distract myself and I and I
want instant thrills that are followed
by continuing to chase that thing. Yeah.
>> What team were you betting on, too? Cuz
I'll tell you what I've been on it.
>> I never did sports betting. I and I
didn't lose I don't think I have like a
gambling addiction, but I I would I
would go and I don't gamble anymore,
I'll say that.
>> I'll bet.
>> do slots.
>> Oh, you do slots, yeah?
>> spins.
$5 spin, have a slap at the pokies.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> I would love, dude, to times I like this
time I didn't I was just in Las Vegas,
but I would I'd like to slip down there
at night when nobody would be around and
I'd sit there and play some slots, just
putting in 20 bucks, 40 bucks.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> You know, and just [\h__\h] try to get a
little bit of money out of China.
>> [laughter]
>> You know, I'd yell at the machine. I'd
be like, "We're going to [\h__\h] get
your cash, you know?"
>> We're coming, Beijing.
>> Yeah, we're coming, dude.
>> Congratulations.
Poor boy.
>> Yeah.
>> You've popped the pig big. The The It's
It's [laughter] so funny cuz it will
give you and this is not a bit. Heaven
forbid I do a bit. But it'll be like,
"Congrajudention.
Congribidibus.
You've won. You've been awarded dollar."
Like you won a dollar, like a singular
Judeo-Christian dollar.
>> And they sound it out. It takes for And
you're like, "Fuck, dude, if I would
have just called it a way even I could
just [\h__\h] taken a call on a phone and
asked them for $2. I would have made
more money doing something else.
>> You've been accepted into the winner
circle. Press B to trust.
>> And [laughter] then you
like press B and then it's $1.47
and you're like, "Okay, I'm betting $5.
You just told me I lost
>> Yeah, and it's like, "Oh, you've won the
deceased sibling round. We're going to
bring back Anna Marie." And you're like,
"Oh my god, my sister's back. My
sister's back."
>> [laughter]
>> But it's so funny and they're like
>> But that's how it's going to get. Don't
you see where we're going?
>> That's I mean, that's going to be in our
freaking textbooks one of these days.
>> You're going to have to go to the win or
encore or you're going to have to go to
dragon's beard or whatever the casinos
will be named then, you know, or
faggot's realm or whatever they're
called, right? You're going to have to
go to some of these places. Sorry.
>> Yes, go to the circus of life.
>> Or Trump's nuts or whatever the whatever
the casinos are going to be called.
You're going to have to go there in the
Biden's Oculus, right? You're going to
have to go there and they'll be like,
you know, if get four spins and you'll
see your father, you know, and that's
really what it's going to be like.
>> Yes, and you have to keep playing.
You're you will use your social credit
score to go have a round of spins at
John Carpenter's cigarette burns and you
will be lucky to walk out with a
talisman.
>> [laughter]
>> Or an amulet of any repute.
>> Yeah, dude.
>> It's brutal and it's so I always just
think it's so funny how they'll be like,
"Gar gar gar gar gar. You've awarded the
pig some hooves." And then they'll just
like print you out one US dollar. Yeah.
>> [laughter]
[snorts]
>> Yeah, dude.
>> [gasps]
>> What do we I mean, where do we go from
here, you know?
>> Um, what are some things that you feel
like
cuz like I'll go to meetings. I'm going
to go to a meeting probably whenever I
get done with this today.
Um what are some things that the
meetings do for you? Do you notice
something like that over time?
>> Yeah. Um
>> Like going to recovery meetings. There's
a lot of 12-step meetings out there, you
know.
>> Sure. I went this morning in Nashville.
I like to um
at the at a very
>> go to that 7:30 meeting over there?
>> No, it was at um a sober living in
Nashville at 11:30.
>> But
at the at a very base level, what I can
say is that I have never ever walked out
of one feeling worse than I was walking
in. I will always, even if there's two
other people in there and I've been to
plenty of things like that, um newer
meetings or smaller towns.
Um I'll always hear something that
relates to my life or relates to how I
want to have my life be. So, it's just I
like to meet random people, too. It's
like makes me uncomfortable.
And then when I leave, I feel like I did
something good cuz I know it's good for
me.
>> And I know I need it.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it kind of cultivates a part
of you that you can't even access. Like
I think for me like I share in meetings.
I try to share um most of the meetings
that I go to.
Um and I always wonder kind of why. It's
like
uh
And then I was like, oh well, when I was
a kid, I didn't there wasn't like a
place that was safe where I could speak
up, right? Like at our house, you
couldn't speak up. Nobody cared how you
felt. There wasn't even I didn't even
know I had any feelings except that I
wasn't feeling good.
>> Sure.
>> And it was like nobody and that was our
whole like system at home.
>> Yeah. [snorts]
>> And so like sometimes when I go in
there, it's like
well, this is a place that's safe enough
where I can speak up even if I don't
know exactly what I'm going to say or
how exactly I feel. It gives me like a
little bit of space to explore it. So,
it's almost like sometimes I feel like
I'm it's almost like the kid me or the
younger me that's in there that's kind
of like I mean, it's an adult me, but it
kind of like um it helps me honor a
little bit of that. Like here's this
younger me that never got to speak up.
So, in here today, I'm going to sit here
with you and we're going to see you I'm
saying we're going to speak up for
ourselves.
>> Yeah, that that is really beautiful. I
can definitely um
identify with some of those um
sentiments from feeling like a bit
voiceless when I was younger. Yeah, it
is it's so nice to anytime I've I'll try
to like prepare something smart to say,
it'll be like you're a bum you're a
troglodyte. Like, I'm a mute.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm a mute, deaf, speechless. But, I'm
like, it's summer's summer's hard. And
they're like, What the who what are you?
Not even who are you, what are you and
why? The big three.
Um
>> Then when somebody will share something
in there and that you've been wanting to
say your whole life or hear
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> and you'll finally hear it or or and
you're like, oh, I feel like a part of
me like will almost like the locks will
like turn and a new door will open.
>> Yeah, you feel like a weight has been I
can't even describe how it feels. Like,
really get involved in that stuff and
um it it's so crazy. It makes you feel
like you know, I'm of the belief that
the universe is all mental and it it
unfolds just for us, you know, how can
it not? Our life experiences are
designated and interpreted solely for us
and
when I'm in there almost every time
something will happen that's so kismet
or a synchronicity and you'll hear
something you were just thinking about
or something that's upcoming you've been
worried about. And you're like, what are
the odds of that? And it happens almost
every day where you're like, I'm on the
right path, you know? When you do the
right things, you get the right things.
It might not be the things you want, but
the things that you need at least.
>> And the little things you hear in there,
man.
>> Yeah.
>> The little things like uh contrary
action. Like, there's a lot of times I
won't won't want to if I don't want to
do something
>> Mhm.
>> unless it's for like a reason where
there's like safety concern or something
like that, then I need to consider
trying to go do it. Like, I don't really
need to do this yoga. I don't really
need to go and like walk over to from
neighbor's and drop this off. Just
little it's cuz there's a darker part of
me that wants to me to be by myself that
wants me to stay like isolated and sit
and think and ponder about everything.
And and just learning those things. And
eventually, I have to learn things a
lot,
>> right?
>> I have to learn things a lot. It's like
my forgetter is really big. It's like
It's almost like when I wake up in the
morning, it's like
there's a part of me that's forgotten if
people care about me, that's forgotten
if I care about me, you know, it's not
exact, but there's a lot of like
Somebody comes in almost at night and
cleans like the dry erase boards, you
know?
>> I need to be reminded that
I matter. And at a bigger level, other
people matter more than me. Yeah. Other
people matters, you know, I was the
I was the main actor in my life for so
long, and it was all how things were
affecting me and what I was doing. And
it's so nice to
yeah, just genuinely give a [\h__\h] about
other people.
>> Dude, some of the my best moments are
the my moments are my favorites.
Or if I wake up and my first thought my
first thought about somebody else,
that's almost like, God, thank you. Or
if I'm just driving and I have to
remember something somebody had said
yesterday, like, oh, I'm going to call
them and check them on them about that.
Or something somebody cared about, and I
was like, oh, let me see how that played
out for them. The more those I get,
like, the better it feels.
>> Yeah, cuz we're meant we're meant to
have community. In my mind, it's the
same thing. It'll It's so much easier.
There's a million other things I could
be doing for an hour in a day than doing
that.
But when I'm alone,
if I make an excuse like that, I'll make
another excuse, you know? And I'll make
another excuse, and it may not lead to
drug use, but it definitely will lead to
me having a sadder life. And at the very
least, I don't want that. Yeah. Yeah,
that's that's so
>> And it's like I just remember people
care about me. I walk into a meeting and
I'm like, oh, yeah.
Dude, I remember And it's not that I
forgot them or anything, but it's just
like I have to have this thing
replenished. That's like, yes, your
heart works, you work, you're okay,
things are okay, there might be
problems, but they're not that big, and
everything's going to be okay. It's
almost like you just like
I don't know. It's like church It
definitely is like church. Some people
are like, do you go to church? And it's
like, I don't go to church every week,
but in a way I go to church four or five
times a week. Yeah. You know? And you
feel it. And you feel it.
>> Yeah. Like I walk out of there, I'm
like, okay, if I'm the like
I mean, there's some days when it's
rough. If somebody sit on their phone
next to me the whole meeting, dude.
>> Or there's a kid running around, God
forbid. A little Christmas kid. You can
tell it's like a New Year's Eve baby.
>> Yeah, and he's like, my birthday's
coming up or whatever, and I'm like
>> no, it's not.
No, [laughter] it's not. We're in July.
I can tell you're a New Year's Eve baby.
Get the hell out of here with your
holiday spirits.
>> [laughter]
>> Um
But no, man, I think that community's
great. What do you think if there's
somebody who's scared to try to go to a
first meeting, you know? I'll have
friends that'll ask me sometimes about
like
or what do you say to somebody who's
thinking like, maybe I might be
struggling with this, you know?
>> Sure. Um
Well, something that I go back to is
that it's just so nice to be around
people who
I I I You know, there's a saying uh
there's saying of uh terminal uniqueness
that makes people continue to struggle.
That we think that we're so different in
our suffering. That we're put on this
earth just to suffer, and who am I to
say if that's not the case, but
everything you've been through has
meaning. And of course it has meaning to
you, but it doesn't really have that
much helpful meaning to you, the things
that you've gone through that are really
bad.
Ruminating on that does not help, but
when you put it out of you
and and you see that it helps someone,
even just for a day, like being around
people who also hurt that way, it's just
an incredible feeling. It's not a chore.
It's not something you have to go do.
It's something I look forward to doing.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz it's so nice to look around and go,
oh my god, I'm not this little freak.
Yeah. I'm not this little guy that God
forgot, you know? I'm someone that has
purpose, even if it's just for today. I
can have a purpose of hanging out with
these people and
I know that when I'm in there I feel
better. Just for even if it's just for
that hour, even if I leave and I get
back and I feel like [\h__\h] again and I'm
going a little crazy and I'm riffing a
little too hard about the wrong things
in my little brain. Um
It's a safe place. Like and I hate to
use that term, but it's you know places
like that are just it's somewhere
completely free of judgment. It's so
beautiful. Yeah. It's so beautiful and
there's nothing else like it.
>> I agree.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, it's crazy sometimes when people
like, "Hey, do we come do this?" I'm
like, "Nah, I don't know if I'm doing
that, you know? I don't know if I'm
driving over to meet you at a
Whataburger or something, you know?"
Just because they're popping off cuz
it's new or whatever and the seats are
clean or whatever still.
>> Yeah, I'm not going animal style. You
can't make me.
>> Yeah, but you're like, "Hey, you want to
drive 20 minutes across town to go to
like this 11:30 a.m. like meeting? It's
going to be mostly older folks in this
church." And I'm like, "Dude, yeah. That
[\h__\h] sounds popping."
>> I dig wisdom. I Dude, I love to talk to
some old farmer.
Ooh wee! I get off on talking to an old
farmer.
>> Our plants got to aids. You're like, "I
don't know if that's what happened."
>> He goes, "When my arm's crying, I got to
feed it."
>> [laughter]
>> "When that baby's crying, I got to feed
it." And you go, "Hell yeah."
>> "Don't come on my back and tell me it's
raining, you know?" [\h__\h] like that.
You're like, "Yeah."
>> [laughter]
>> People always have crazy quotes.
Um but no, man. It's definitely like
I don't know. And it's there for you.
It's like if you if you have a tough
time, if you leave if you come in or
out, the meetings are there and you can
go back, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> It's just so nice to like something that
really sat with me this last go around
when I was trying to get my life
together again is just the simple
thought that I don't have to live like
that. Like whatever is making me feel
like my life is
for want of a better term, escalating
towards some terminal velocity where
I've had so many times in my life where
I feel like this is going to end bad.
I'm either I'm, you know, I'm working
too much or I'm worried about the wrong
[\h__\h] or I'm, you know, I'm using again
and I know it's going to end bad. And to
know I don't ever have to feel like that
again cuz I know that I'm in control of
my emotions now and it's
so [snorts] great. I like to let
yourself have peace. It's so hard. It's
like the hardest thing in life
>> is it hard, man?
>> That's such a fascinating thing. I have
never heard it said like that. To let
yourself have peace. Yeah, like I don't
want to let myself have peace, man. It's
like
or I don't know if I don't think or I'm
not saying I don't but it's like that
would be the like yeah, I don't do I not
deserve like what is that?
>> I I don't know if it's something just
the way that we're wired where
>> Cuz that's it. That's some of the wiring
is right there. Why won't I let myself
have peace? I have friends that are that
like
And I've struggled. I've had some tough
years over, you know, over the years for
sure and
uh but I've had some friends that
won't won't won't get close to it, you
know?
>> Yeah.
>> Won't try to get close to the fire. They
want to just keep keep trying to do it.
>> What's familiar.
>> It's familiar and there's a thing of
like I'll figure this out. You know what
I'm saying? Like
like
>> I've gotten myself this far.
>> Right. And the world feels like you I I
don't know when I was a younger I put a
chip on my shoulder like the world was
an enemy and I'm going to figure this
out and watch me.
And then the worst part is if you have
some successes in your life or things
that go kind of your way, it's hard to
realize that like something, you know,
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz then you feel like oh well, I'm
doing I'll figure this out, too.
>> Yeah, cuz I did this for myself. I I
uprooted myself. I made this happen. But
then also I've made a lot of the bad
things in my life happen,
>> [laughter]
>> you know, drinking toss, walking down
the road, having a little slip and
slide.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Carmically speaking. I'm a karmic patsy.
I'm a I'm a charlatan of redemption. I'm
a test man. But
>> Dude, you're the Jack Ruby [laughter]
of that realm,
>> I am Jack Ruby and I am Nikola Tesla and
we are building a free energy circuit
that Edison will shut down.
>> Yeah, for [laughter] sure.
Um
>> Yeah, it's but it that ego is so good
cuz yeah, it's like no one really helped
me become a comedian. No one taught me
how to tell jokes. No one you know, I
slept in my car for a long time. I I
spent my whole life working on this
thing. So when we're able to turn that
into something that is working, of
course I think
we're apt to believe like, oh, I'll turn
this around too by myself.
That's just you know, we both know
that's not the case. It's not possible.
>> Yeah, it's just willpower. It's vibrant
willpower. I'm amazed at the willpower
sometimes of people that struggle. Like
I have friends whose parents have her
out on the streets and or have been
struggling for 20, 30 years, you know,
and uh
and I'm sure some of them like some of
them even asked me, why do you think
they say what's going on? You know, it's
like I don't know, but you just try to
talk with somebody about that stuff and
it's just the willpower of of some of of
alcohol of of people that are in
recovery of alcoholism of alcoholics.
It's man, it's strong. It's like
I'll figure this out. Everything I'll
turn this around. Or then sometimes I
bet you just get
uh you build you just get trapped in
shame and then you just want to stay
away from your life because you feel
like, I don't want to go around these
people because I'll only make things
worse for them. That's got to be kind of
a crazy trap.
>> Yeah, that you're too far gone and
you're like radioactive.
>> Yeah, it's heartbreaking.
>> Yeah, definitely. But that people you
feel like people would be better off
without you, which is such a dangerous
thought that is never ever ever ever
true.
>> Mhm, yeah.
>> Yeah, it's never true.
>> Yeah.
>> Um you've you've uh you've talked about
the occult a lot,
>> [laughter]
>> right? And I feel like you've gone
around the up and down those realms.
You've referenced you low-key your
closet occult, people say, okay?
>> [laughter]
>> Occult adjacent.
>> No, I've read about all kinds of
religions and stuff, so
sometimes I'll I'll throw some buzzwords
out there.
>> I do like to Why do you do that?
>> some buzzies. I'll do a little buzz.
I'll catch you in a little in a little
fly trap.
>> Hershiser of throwing buzzwords out
there?
>> K.C. Orange
>> [laughter]
>> K.C. Orangethorpe James Simpson Rocca.
>> No.
Orel Hershiser.
>> Oh, yes. Yes. Yes.
>> Sorry, he was a I think he was one of
the best pitchers before you were born.
Dude, when I was a kid, like the best
pitcher was kind of a old white.
>> [laughter]
>> It was like, okay.
>> Randy Johnson?
>> Uh-huh. It was before him. It was like
Randy Johnson's daddy or whatever. And
Randy Johnson. Yeah, bring up Orel
Hershiser.
There he is, dude. He's a legend. Yeah,
him and Walker Buehler actually look
alike. But from Buffalo, New York, man,
he's a legend. But he was a legend when
I was growing up, you know? It was just
like a white guy that was that was able
to do it. And then things got uh
Latino and just more diverse. Um but
what I was going to ask you, yeah, where
do you feel like we're at spiritually as
as a people right now? Do you Do you
feel like we're in a tough spot? Do you
see a a different future for us? Like
what do you really see having somebody
who like kind of is willing to kind of
massage the crystal ball of different
realms?
>> That is a interesting question and uh
uh
happy to be here, but it it that's
that's difficult. I think for me as part
of uh a better life that I've tried to
live um
yeah, I love reading about different
kinds of uh positive philosophy from
antiquity. So, you know, stoicism,
Marcus Aurelius, um up through
different I've had different times in my
life where I was a
more or less a believer of existential
nihilism that life had no purpose, that
we were put into this world simply um
from a dying god, sort of a gnostic
worldview.
Of um
we don't have any purpose because we
will ultimately die, right? So, in doing
so, the end justifies the means in the
sense of whatever we end up doing it
does not serve any sort of greater good.
But, I believe the opposite of that
today. Um I think as human beings
and uh these thoughts are sort of a
mishmash of various other things. Mostly
the tenets of hermeticism and some sort
of uh cabal.
Kabbalah.
Not cabalic uh not like a cult, but
the universe is always in motion and
we're a part of the universe, right? So,
I know that my life serves a greater
good today.
And I also know that I can be a driving
force in my life while also knowing that
I can only drive so far.
So, all I can choose to do is, as they
say, the right-hand path of doing the
right thing and the next right thing and
um if I do do something wrong to a
friend, small things. The mistakes I
make today are smaller. I can be snippy.
I can be rude. I can be not emotionally
available.
Um I can immediately act to correct
that, right? So, it's some iteration of
karma and some iteration of the
understanding that life is
suffering. You know, it hurts to know
that we're alive and it to know that
we're
worth more than we'll be given.
Um
but
>> Dang, that's crazy. I never heard that
before.
>> Yeah, you know, people the meaning of
life is just it's the small things. It's
to mean something in a moment-by-moment
basis and to do things without the
purpose of distraction. So,
it's so much easier, you know, we've
both struggled with drugs and alcohol to
to turn that knob off.
But, I'm going to have to wake up again
tomorrow.
And that's the thing about like
developing a drug habit is like I would
always be so furious when I would wake
up and go, "Oh my god, I have to do this
again. I can't believe I have to do this
again."
But, I'm of the belief that we were all
created so the universe can understand
itself,
you know? So,
>> Mhm.
>> I'm simply a
a cog in a in such a greater machine of
I only exist because at the end of my
timeline I serve some greater purpose,
you know, for
the creator of the universe, whatever
you want to call that. Um
>> And who do you hope it is? Like say if
it is like a And I think that's
beautifully put, dude. I really do.
That's pretty cool, man.
You're eloquent speaker, you're going to
be a great uh screenwriter.
>> Thank you for saying that.
>> Yeah. It's going to be exciting, man. I
admire the fact that you're willing to
to do something that you want to do,
right?
Like I think it's easy to get trapped
and like
there's popularity here, there's some
money here, there's reward, there's like
ego reward here. But is this really like
what I really want to do? Like sometimes
I really want to just focus on learning
Spanish and be a writer, right? Some of
those Those are things that I think,
right?
>> That gives me self-worth.
>> Right. And but then you get caught in
different things and sometimes they're
blessings and it's great pasts and
stuff, but it's like, yeah, do we reward
like that
you know, do we reward that thing inside
of us that also we that that was the
reason maybe we started out wanting to
be creative? Like sometimes you'll get
on such a path that you never get back
to those things sometimes.
>> Yeah, it was so it's been so nice to
to bring it back to comedy in any
capacity, to do things just for fun, to
go do an open mic at like a hot dog
stand. Yeah. It's like I used to love
stuff like that. I used to live for [\h__\h]
like that. And then when you get caught
up in all the numbers and how are the
tickets and
When you get caught up in all that,
it
some of it gets lost.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'm tired of losing stuff, you know?
I needed to trim some of my hedges,
right? Tall poppy syndrome. I needed to
cut down some of these egotistical parts
of my life that I know don't serve me.
And then it's a daily thing of figuring
out, you know, chipping away at the
block of happiness and trying to get a
firmer picture of what that looks like,
yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Hard to say.
>> I think well said.
Um in the end, when we get there,
>> Mhm.
>> do you
and it's um and we realize, oh, this was
just a big masked singer, right?
>> Sure.
>> And they take it off they take the mask
off, who do you hope it is?
>> Bill Paxton, yeah.
>> Who played for the Bulls?
>> Um
>> Is that Bill Paxton?
>> That's John Paxton.
>> John Paxton.
>> So uh Bill Paxton, um American actor who
was in Aliens and um
Frailty. Um just famed character actor
Bill Paxton who did have leading man
potential and was sometimes given the
option to exercise that.
Um died in a medical
>> [laughter]
>> died in a medical malpractice incident
and
>> [snorts]
>> he um he once told
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, he got malpracticed to heaven.
>> Oh, that's what happened with Kanye's
mom. It was him and Kanye's mom then
maybe.
>> Yeah, I think they were doing like a
dual surge or surgery or something. They
were doing sutures or something. It was
a suture day.
>> Oh, it's probably one of those new cuz
they're I know that insurance is
offering if you both get surgery on the
same day with someone you don't know.
It's like I it's like um
>> Cancels out.
>> Then yeah, well, it's cheaper.
>> Sure. Yeah, it's half as much for twice
the people, so.
>> [laughter]
>> It's a new and they're doing that new
drive-by surgery where some guy just
reaches out of like a Yeah.
>> Ow.
>> [laughter]
>> But yeah, he
>> There's a lot of great offers coming
from the gods above.
>> Oh, yes, sure. We're simply vessels,
man.
>> Bill Paxton died in February 2017 from a
fatal stroke. Oh, man. 11 days after
undergoing heart surgery, his family
filed a wrongful death lawsuit accusing
the surgeon and hospital of medical
malpractice alleging the doctor used an
unnecessary unconventional technique.
See
>> Uh-uh.
>> Full circle riff, put a bow on it.
>> AKA Cedars-Cyanide, a lot of people call
it.
>> [laughter]
>> Which is another
>> And they are coming out with a yogurt,
I've heard. So, that's good.
>> We are doing squatter's rights on that
riff.
We are here to cut the ribbon on that
>> Um before you go, Casey, uh
the riffs you are you're there's you're
you're a different instrument, man.
You're a different instrument. How do
you best set yourself up for the ability
to riff? Do you have to do a certain
sequence of events before you go on?
Like, and not to put a lot of pressure
on yourself, but if you notice certain
things lead to better tuning for
yourself as an instrument.
>> Oh, that's a good question. Um
without giving away my entire process,
which I am not even capable of
replicating, which really gets me in a
bind.
>> [laughter]
>> When I can't even do my own act and I'm
the one who does it.
>> Yikes.
>> I like to do I like to have some tent
poles. So, I'll go out there, I'll cause
a bit of a fuss.
I'll cause a fuss.
And I like to I'll say this, I like to
go up there and sing cuz it gets me out
of my head. So, I learned a long time
ago the most embarrassing thing you can
ever do is try to sing genuinely like in
a circumstance that does not call for
it.
So, I'll go up there, I'll do a little
grunge number.
Woo, woo, do a little Alabama Shakes,
Brittany Howard. And
I can feel [clears throat]
super embarrassed and then I go, "Well,
surely nothing for the rest of this hour
will feel like how that just felt."
So, that allows me to just sort of peel
the mask off and then do a big
Scooby-Doo reveal
of me to myself in the mirror.
And then I do a quick wink. And
I will have some tent poles. So, I'll
try to do three jokes that I know I'm
going to tell.
So, before I go up and I do my hour,
I'll look at I I'll know three jokes
that going to say.
>> Okay.
>> And then I'll do a joke.
Joke. Yeah. Joke.
And then from there, hopefully I've
gotten about 10 to 20 laughs at this
point. And if if you extrapolate, let's
say the room's 500, which is bigger than
rooms that I do. Let's say in a perfect
world I'm headlining 500 seaters.
If I get 10 laughs out of 500, I go,
"Ooh, I only got 490 to go."
So that
>> [laughter]
>> How about that?
I I'll do a couple jokes up top and
that'll give me the confidence I need to
string it all together.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. But I you know, we're
>> [laughter]
>> But I have like a thousand half-sentence
jokes, so if I ever lose my train of
thought, I'll just like hit them with
I'll just do a quick stinky.
So that's like an example of a joke,
yeah.
>> Oh, dude. You're like an Easter basket
that has matches in it, dude. You're
like there's just [laughter] something
going on there.
>> Careful with the plastic wrap. You'll
set the whole thing off.
>> Cadbury and diesel.
Uh it's just [laughter] yeah, there's
something just so charming about about
your presentation of yourself.
>> Thanks [snorts] for saying that.
>> It's the truth.
>> Thanks.
>> I hope you feel that in a in a place
where we need to feel things that are
important. And not that not but I just
think like yeah, I don't know. I don't
mean that cuz I'm saying that to you,
but I just think yeah, there's a
um
I don't know.
It's a great thing to watch. You're a
great thing to watch, Casey Rocket.
>> Thanks. Me and my friends watched No
Offense on Netflix, your special,
right when I started comedy and it was
very formative for me. And I thought it
was so funny and I'd never seen anything
like it. So I really appreciate you
saying that. Thanks, man.
>> Well, you bet, dude. I'm glad that we've
been able to communicate, man. I hope we
can do it more. Um I think I'm going to
try to come out there tonight.
>> Come riff or at least come hang out. You
don't have to riff, but come hang out.
It'll be so fun.
>> It would be so fun, dude. I think I'm
going to go up because I think it's
probably what I need to do, contrary
action.
>> It's a my crowds, and I'm sure your
crowds, too, but they're so they would
just be so happy to see you. You'll have
so much fun.
>> Yeah.
>> It'd be great.
>> All right.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, I'm coming then.
>> Yes.
>> Um what time is your show at?
>> 7:00.
>> It is?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I was supposed to go to a 6:30
meeting, but maybe I can find a six or I
can maybe I can go to one after. Um
>> Yeah.
>> Uh Casey Rocket, you got some tour dates
coming up?
>> Yeah, I'm on the road. Uh yeah,
caseyrocketcomedy.com.
Uh
>> Up in Liberty Township over there,
Cincinnati. That's a good place over
there.
>> Doing some more Funny Bones this year.
Um one thing I want to plug, I have an
hour of my stand-up on my Patreon. It's
$6, and all the money goes to harm
reduction programs in Chicago. So,
community outreach, clean uh needles,
harm reduction, all kinds of good stuff
that helps people get
help uh people get the help that they
need. So, yeah, my Patreon's on there,
and um if you feel like doing that, just
know that all that money goes to
charity. So, yeah.
>> Dude, that's awesome, man.
Um congrats on all the success, dude.
Thanks for talking with us. We had
Liberty Township. What were some of the
other ones? Let me just rattle them off
real quick. Uh Columbus, Ohio. I love
being in Ohio, dude. St. Petersburg,
Florida. Asheville, North Carolina. Have
you been there?
>> Um I have not done the Orange Peel yet,
but I've been to Asheville. It's so
cool.
>> So
>> offered a three uh
threesome there by
uh
older mixed couple.
>> [laughter]
>> One of them wearing who I think was
wearing a Ed Reed jersey.
Uh we got Chicago back at Zanies,
Indianapolis, Indianapolis, Louisville,
a lot of places. Um you can check uh
check him out online on his website,
caseyrocket.com.
>> caseyrocketcomedy.com
>> Yeah, thank you, guys.
>> And uh
and before you go, I would just want to
get this note in for
uh viewers. Know that the Jasper Mall in
Jasper, Alabama has not officially
closed. It is still operating though in
a very reduced and dead mall state.
>> Dead mall state, that's what's going to
happen when the nuclear family
collapses.
>> Not to be confused with Dead Mall 5
actually, who I think is still doing
well. Can you bring up Dead Mall?
>> Yeah, I think that's one of
Marshmallow's
>> [clears throat]
>> aliases. So, it's like Dead Mouse. Yeah,
he's in the he's What do they call it?
The Marshmallow extended universe, so.
>> Yes, Dead face reveal.
>> Okay, spoiler alert.
>> Didn't know that was him. I hope he's
doing good. Anyway,
um cool man. Dude, thank you so much for
your time. Have a great show tonight.
I'm going to come up there and uh
I'll figure it out when I get up there.
>> Yeah, I wouldn't have it any other way.
And I'll And I'll say one more thing.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> Um
there's more to life than riffs, but
there's not more to riffs than life.
>> Mhm.
>> That's it.
>> [laughter]
See [snorts] you at the mall.
>> Now, I'm just floating on the breeze and
I feel I'm falling like these leaves. I
must be
cornerstone.
Oh, but when I [music] reach that
ground, I'll share this peace of mind I
found. I can feel it
in my bones.
But, it's going to take
a little